so the audubon society is a group
dedicated to conserving
the bird population and um
you may think that there's no way to
politicize or sort of wokify
birds
but you would be wrong so let's put the
tweet up first this is from the audubon
society they say this pride month
audubon partnered with
drag queen and intersectional fem wait
sorry drag queen an intersectional
environmentalist patty gonia
patty gonia okay i just got that
uh to bring you birds tell us
before we continue i just need to can we
just stop for a moment on um
drag queen an intersectional
environmentalist
birds tell us the song of the meadow
lark a message of hope for the future of
our planet as we face climate change if
we choose to listen okay so this is a
song
by patty gonia the intersectional
environmentalist drag queen
and this is all to uh this is all for
the sake of defending
the birds and conserving the bird
population
uh let's let's listen to the song
together
[Music]
could you stop pause it there for a
second
that guy can we go back to what he looks
like is his uh what this guy is dressed
as because i just i i always ask this
question and yeah
i don't understand what is what are the
drag queens going for like who
who are you supposed to be
why is it that drag queens always look
like the evil stepmothers in disney
films i i just don't understand it
anyway we haven't heard the song yet so
i don't want i don't want to trash the
guy too much until we hear the song
let's keep going
birds tell us
birds tell us that the world is changing
that the climate is changing
they sing it over us
and around us
in their songs
and in the songs they no longer sing
[Music]
will we choose to listen
birds tell us
do you know why birds sing just before
dawn no i don't
people believe it's to tell each other
that they made it through the night no
it's not that's not i don't believe that
as a way of saying i'm still here no
it's like it's mating it's not nothing
to do with this
as a way of saying i made it that's not
why bird sings that's incorrect bird
information this is the autobahn society
you think you at least get some correct
bird facts out of this thing
birds sing to let us all know that
they're still here they survive the
night i don't think so don't turn it
down keep keep playing it we're going to
play this entire thing
i've decided
this is character building for all of us
we're going to make it through this
together it's a feathered thing perched
upon the soul
singing
never ceasing
giving
wings this is not supposed to be this is
not supposed to be funny i don't think
they're going for humor now this is
actually
can be a quiet sound
what emotional reaction are we supposed
to be having
oh it's over
how am i how are we suppose what
what are they going for is i think that
we're supposed to be
like emotionally affected by that
it is true it's it is just they're
beyond parody the left is
quite literally beyond parody at this
point
but i will say one thing watching that i
i am getting some great ideas for my own
interpretive dance so that's the one
positive from this
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content